when I was a kid I would spend hours and
my cousin's just smashing buttons in
Street Fighter 2 until one of us would
throw a fireball or esri would say I
don't exactly know what I was doing but
the sound and the motion of the Hadouken
have been ingrained in my mind forever
and seemingly and brought our gaming
culture for that matter that guy he
would go Hadouken I don't get what kind
of a token do you want me to do because
there's an Omaha tokens fire flame and
Oh King you don't have to be a fighting
game pro or even like gamer for that
matter to know that this move has
stretched far beyond its roots in a
popular culture and that left me
wondering why is the Hadouken so
important there's clearly a lot to learn
about the Hadouken and I thought what
better way then to throw myself into the
deep end
and fight a legend his name is John Choi
and by D pan I mean fighting him online
and likely getting destroyed
fighting games in general but kind of
controlling your space what the fireball
allows you to do is control a very large
amount of space very safely it's just an
extension of your normal attack you
could kind of say mr. kite just covers
up bigs you know space the great
advantage is that you can't destroy the
fireball with normal means this is a
strategy guide for Street Fighter Alpha
2 from 1996 and wouldn't you know it
there's an entire section for Ryu
Hadouken alone who wrote this thing why
you you played John Troy for this clip
this is you and him yes it is you know
what's funny as I made it like five
seconds into the clip and I was gonna
say the cool thing about fireballs is
like when you throw a Hadouken right or
any projectile on any fighting game it
travels across the screen it goes it
doesn't sting and then the very next
thing that happens of course is you're
like I got a job you know when I was
first starting out knowing arcade
culture you gotta put your corner up and
there's a lot of long lines everywhere
there's no training mode there's no
videos there's no youtube there's no
internet so as soon as you find out the
technique that works you would just you
know beat that to the ground why would I
do any other move like if it still works
right fighting games in general when you
think of them you think about two kind
of characters and the thing that makes
them abandoned just walking back and
forth and swinging at each other with
punches and kicks is fireballs or
projectiles Hadouken the feeling of I
can no longer just stand here and walk
back and forth and do what I want to do
I have to jump you jump and the first
thing that happens is he just walks up
sure you can and uppercuts you and I
think even if you're a super casual
fighting game thing you will understand
Hadouken x' and shoryuken it's like just
throwing a fireball and what they should
jump over the fireball you uppercut them
it's like such a classic tale is all
this time kind of feeling if you've ever
played Mario you've jumped over a
Hadouken right like it's a little like a
Goomba on the ground that's a Hadouken
that you have to jump over otherwise you
know you're gonna get hit by them or
something so as a video game player
you understand it as an obstacle on the
screen that you have to navigate around
the choices I blocked the fireball I
jumped the fireball should I even be
brave enough to throw a fireball back
what if he jumps over mine I feel I feel
for you because there's no escape on
screen the Hadouken was about
controlling space or conditioning your
opponent but in the real world
it had a far more profound impact on
people's personal lives like these folks
for example into camera or into Kamaka
Street Fighter is probably the game that
has led me into getting into covering
video games in a sense you know fighting
games were a very social thing you had
to go to our Cades and and see other
people and interact with other people I
met people that went on to work I did
another play just like playing fighting
games but but most importantly like like
playing a lot of Street Fighter 2 Street
Fighter 2 was the first video game I
ever got into and fell in love with my
uncle showed it to me and I've never
played a fighting game before I was very
small I was about five or six and so
there was a character select screen it's
like dude dude dude dude Oh chun-li she
seems cool let's see what she's about I
remember playing through fire one when I
was child before I had any ability or
understanding of how to play fighting
games properly you're playing it you're
like I don't know I'm kicking these guys
it doesn't move very well but whatever
and then someone's like oh that one guy
can shoot a gun and you're like I don't
think that's rebounding I don't think
that's real that sense of community was
really interesting and the rumors that
went around no one automatically knew
how to do the special moves in the game
it was totally hidden you know it wasn't
something that they were advertising
like shoot fire out of your fists and do
all this other stuff also the waste
Street Fighter 1 processed input was so
much worse than Street Fighter 2 that
even if you step up to that machine
knowing exactly what you're doing it's
not guaranteed that it's gonna come out
the way you expect so I think that made
it even more hidden because someone
would say like here's how you do it and
you go try and go that's crap no way
that doesn't that doesn't work you're
crazy
right before Street Fighter 2 even came
out that suddenly I finally saw it and
we're like Oh what he's he's doing a
thing there's a thing here
so in a Super Nintendo when you're
performing a Hadouken it looks something
like this it's a down downward forward
and then forward punch when it's done a
full motion it looks like that or in
proper terminology quarter circle
forward very few other games were asking
you to do those sorts of inputs you know
the things that Street Fighter 2 wanted
you to do I just didn't have the
execution down and it took time it took
a lot of years actually probably like a
year or two even to actually get that
stuff down the motion that you do is
almost mirrored in the character on
screen it just feels natural you don't
it's it's more it's almost more visual
when you're doing it as much as it is on
screen but like you can see it there
it's like a quarter circle forward and
then when you hit punch the the Hadouken
comes up so you're almost like you're
doing it on screen or whatever what's
happening on screen is what you do with
your hand is or sir who came up with
this wonderful move well it was this guy
Takashi
Nisha Yama the lead designer of Street
Fighter 1 Takashi was inspired by 70s
anime called space battleship yamato
where the signature ship had a move
called hadoo howe word collect a bunch
of energy and then shoot it through
space which is pretty much the hadouken
hadouken is is a special move you know
those those special moves are what
defines the characters in the game it
what it's what makes you think back to
Street Fighter fondly and you think
about like oh yeah there was that little
green guy that you know flew across the
screen as a ball or he turned into
electricity it creates that kind of a
mind game that makes fighting games so
fun fighting games are not only about
like the execution of like inputting
commands to do stuff right but also the
the mental game of what is my opponent
gonna do here am i brave enough to jump
this should I be like careful enough to
just wait here and wait it out like what
am I gonna do in those situations and
that kind of test of willpower is what
makes that one special move so important
so after Street Fighter 2 honed in and
mastered the Hadouken it's pretty much
impossible to find a fighting game that
didn't have a projectile morale combat
world heroes fight fever Darkstalkers
primal rage clay fighter is killer
instinct even Tekken eventually got a
hadouken fire ball thing and that even
extends to other games and pop culture
fallout 2 has a reference called duty
black ops I'm pretty sure in Dumon the
Imps throw their little fireballs at
times it really looks a lot like a Duke
in movies like Shazam and of course TV
shows like Family Guy there's also a lot
of references and hip-hop music
specifically little Wayne has a whole
lyric and rollin doja cat captain Murphy
there's even an English pin just simply
called Hadouken furthermore the Hadouken
seems to resonate with a bunch of
wrestlers Xavier woods and Kenny Omega
specifically seems to be tossing those
things out a lot and high school
wrestling there's quite a few clips
online and I don't even know how to
scratch the surface when it comes to
memes I think that sweet fire too was an
effective template or like a successful
starting point for what came afterwards
for the world of fighting games I think
that people looked at this game and saw
that it was successful and what worked
and what didn't work if you think of
Street Fighter 2 and you think about
Street Fighter in general you see Ryo
you see chun-li and were you doing
Hadouken and that's just like something
synonymous with that game I feel like
that's just the part of Street Fighter
that transcended and became part of pop
culture when i say yeah i commentate
competitive fighting games for a living
they say like oh yeah i used to play
back in the arcades you know I used to
know about Ryu and Ken oh and that guy
you would go Haru and they know right
they just know they just do this noise
that is nowhere near what the character
makes and I'm like exactly yes that is
perfectly acceptable we right even if
you've not played a fighting game in 20
years the Hadouken is pretty much the
same it works the exact same way which
is something that's so perfect and like
unbelievable like it hasn't evolved so
far since 20 years ago that you don't
like not recognize it you can perform
that input on any fighting game still
today and with some number of the
characters something cool will happen
it's shooting a fireball out of your
fists at its most basic level you
get into like God was a translate to
it's like energy wave fist I'm making a
problem that's right okay all right
a lot of the people that were part of
that exploration of street fight and
fighting games back then are still in
the community now there are you know
kind of leaders of the community taking
the fighting game fandom worldwide and
kind of like championing gave the
worldwide and holding these big
tournaments like Evo without what
happened then that sense of like
grassroots propagation of information
and and trial and error I don't think
the fine young community would be as
strong as it is today over the past
three weeks I have learned that the
Hadouken has had an undisputable mark on
the fighting game genre
simply put fighting games will never be
the same and that is due in part to the
fireball and no fighting a fireball
Legend are talking to a commentator
hasn't magically made me any better at
the video game but what it's given me is
a broader understanding of the connected
culture surrounding fighting games much
of which started on a rumor that a dude
in a video game from 1987 apparently had
a gun so the next time you face a
fighting game and you see a player toss
out a projectile you have the Hadouken
to thank for that
Hadouken hey folks thanks for watching
this episode of remember when we're
trying a lot of different stuff for this
show so please feel free in the comments
to let us know if you liked it if you
didn't like it and maybe if there's any
old stories you want to see retold with
new perspectives and while you're here
if you're not already consider
subscribing I personally would
appreciate it anyways I'm Kurt til next
time see ya